there is no Orchestra like at the Oscars
that's gonna cut me short right alright
so this is my amazing team I want to
thank first and foremost for this
incredible week we had all the other
fellow filmmakers Shawn Godfrey and his
team who made this possible lots of
logistics yeah the members who voted for
us who invited us and of course our
school Hamburg media school professor we
had writing a who's a incredibly devoted
man pity man from Stefan coma who were
my brilliant teachers I want to thank
Patrizia who saw this coming a year ago
and and PIPA and Anya and a gram and
color and but and and Radhika you were
our family during the past two years I'm
a little nervous I hope I want to thank
the film aboard Hamburg this whole time
if a Hobart and Molly Karbala and their
crew I want to thank a commissioning
editor dr. Claudia Kaczynski thank you
very much for making a film with that
takes place in Turkey spoken in Turkish
for German television that's I think
that's something really to notice I want
to thank my Turkish team Ezzor who
became a brother to me
sanam burrows Mustafa be junetta Saddam
igreja Bobby SD so lucky Sam Sartaj will
honk or John Bilson and our crazy
captain Ali
Dan Majerle team Claudia Yin Marvin
Stefan Judy and steno saga David cotton
who's here today and meet her meet her
thank you very much guys
a special thing to Peter stats for his
wisdom and elegance
our amazing families Medina and Sonia
who came all the way from China to
Istanbul to help us let that sinking
market on my second mother whom whom we
stayed with two three months Jonin and
Java here my my sister's my mother who's
here Sansa's each visual Muslim garden
and my father who had who had his
problems with me becoming a filmmaker
but now but now he's fine I guess he
changed his profile picture on facebook
to a search of the and I really do think
that like I am the sum of all the
defining encounters I've had in my life
and one of them was first and foremost
Jo Clippard my author my writer whom I
made three films with and and guilt
you're just remember his name he's in
the finest like one of the finest really
authors
then my amazing DP Flo and Mark who's
not just amazing he's also handsome and
every actor
every actor will perform better when
he's behind the camera and and then
there is a wonderful Alexander stop my
producer without whom who heard insane
devotion nothing would have happened
like that it was just really tensed in
Istanbul it was politically tensed and
it was her intelligence her kindness and
her her beauty that made this all
possible when we just think it's almost
over let me just think also my professor
energy hood who's not here today but who
believed in me from the very very first
film I would be ashamed to show to
anybody today but he believed in me and
then I want to thank my longtime Life
Companion friend Johannes dimke who is
also whom I made started out who had a
big impact on me as an artist and a
person and I wouldn't be the man I am
today and this film wouldn't be the film
it is today if it wasn't for my wife my
soul mate either gentlemen talk sailor
finally the last the magical five words
thank you to the Academy